today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure their internet join
them at expressvpn.com
we have a responsibility to make sure
that we we get to some kind of of sort
of decent
some basic level of decency and equity
in this country you have this winner
take all
uh economy that's just speeding up and
kovid speeding it up
um uh and you're someone who sees the
future
but you know still has the perspective
to know it's like look
like this is gonna be great for some
people and like not great for others
it'd be
awesome if someone was actually trying
to figure out like how to account
for the the latter part of this equation
for me this is not even an issue of
decency or morality though
it could be and it is in part but for me
i still take it back to the selfish
capitalist reason we should want it
which is
if this system works and we ensure that
basic level of decency and opportunity
for everyone
we will get better stuff it means
i will get better founders to invest in
i will get a broader range of founders
to invest in who will build a greater
range of companies to employ more people
to build more dope things you could
frame it as
enlightened self-interest as much as
altruism
[Music]
man it is hard andrew how like
what keeps you going man how do
humanity first thank you far far far
far from where we're at as a country
right now
how do i keep going alexis it's a little
bit like you and you've been
at this for longer than i have in that
you've been someone who can make a
difference in the world
for a number of years and when you can
make that kind of difference it's almost
impossible not to
try you know what i mean uh you know i
mean you've been a
famous entrepreneur and public figure
for longer than i have i'm kind of newly
minted that way
i mean i was a guy before this
you and i do each other from the
entrepreneur zone
you and i met new orleans among other
places um
but uh so for me right now especially in
this time of covid
you feel like there's so many people
hurting and if you can help
then you've got to do everything you can
uh and then there is this entire
election
and it's been kind of mind-boggling for
me that
i may be able to help in that
race too so i've been doing what i can i
campaigned for joe and kamala last
weekend in
philadelphia and looks like they may
have me heading out again on the trail
uh so you know i mean yeah it's
well it's just like i've told my team
and i don't know if the buying team
knows this but
i've told my team to essentially say yes
to anything they want us to do
so it's like they didn't help like i'm
i'm into it
uh so i'm someone and i think you and i
have this in common alexis where action
makes me feel better
you know it's like it's so uh
hard to feel good about things unless
you're doing something about it in my
experience
so as long as i'm active then it's good
for my energy level and mental health
is there gonna be another
run what's the i hope we have not seen
the end of uh
politics and andrew yang
i i will tell you what is in my
heart and gut um and i've been saying to
folks so it's not [ __ ]
uh my goal is just to try and move us
forward as quickly as possible
and solve the biggest problems as
quickly as possible
so if that's as part of an
administration
great if that's running again great uh i
will say that there's nothing
stopping me from running again in the
sense that
it would probably be more fun and easier
next time
so on that level and i want to give you
a shout out alexis personally because
you were one of the
people that actually got behind my
campaign
before it was a mainstream thing to do
and
when you made your move to express your
support for me
um you were one of a fairly
small handful of prominent figures
who've done so at that point so
i you know i just want to express my
personal gratitude to you and
appreciation for
how you really do see things coming yeah
well of course and look i
i think what i saw was
i saw a really good
organic kind of grassroots support i
spend way too much time
paying attention to like the internet
zeitgeist that's been my whole life
right
front row seat to reddit for the last 15
years and then everything else
so and and to the extent that it helps
my job now as an investor
like i pay a lot of attention to to
things and
i think that's become a good a strong
muscle of mine that i've just spent a
lot of time exercising
and then what i saw was also a message
that
admittedly i also connected with a lot
so i was probably putting some my own
bias in there of just wanting to see it
out in the world and in particular
i mean you brought universal basic
income
to a much larger audience to a national
stage
that it's deserved to
to have for a long time i think there's
been
there's been a lot of folks in the tech
world like myself who have tried to talk
about it
in the context of like hey we need to be
prepared for this like we just don't
have
we the the automation revolution that's
happening
um then the book that tipped me off to
this were those two mit professors the
um
robotic age uh the age of hold on the
the um the second machine age secondary
brain you'll brynjolfsson
and uh and um his co-author and heart's
gonna
yeah just because we should look it up
because uh i'm friendly with eric
berniels
and eric and andrew mcafee andrew mcafee
you know that's what i thought
i that maybe i'm just confusing that
name
and so yeah the second machine age
really crystallized it for me
i was asked i was keynoting some
conference where i was interviewing them
and i read the book as prepped for it
and was just like oh my god wow yeah
like this really i mean i
i take it for granted because we live in
a little bubble of tech
where all of these trends are happening
like we work with the founders who are
building the ai systems to create
automated self-checkouts so you can just
walk into a store
grab the coca-cola and walk out and get
charged and that's
we take it for granted that it's
happening because we worked with the
founders for the last few years and like
of course it's happening but then when
you
multiply that out to the effect it has
on the economy
when a bunch of work in say retail which
is a huge employer
gets automated and it is you know a
better user experience it's not just a
cost saving measure
what do you do how do you prepare for
that and how do you get a population not
just
ready um but also ensure that they have
a baseline
decent living and and that's the part
where
i just i'm grateful you you brought it
to national attention
going forward we've got so much more
work to do the
the k-shaped recovery i i mean i
like i live it i see it right i'm having
one of the most productive
years of my career because i'm an
investor in
technology i i know
there are people in my family who are
being crushed by what's happening
because they're on the other side of
that case-shaped recovery
wow and that is
not sustainable it's not sustainable at
all and we need real solutions to help
make sure
that it doesn't lead to to further
crisis
because i look i love the free markets
i love capitalism um we're at a place
now where
you know technology it's so cliche to
say technology disrupts everything but
but kovit has accelerated
the adoption of technology that would
have taken years it's it's happened in
months and if you look at
e-commerce if you look at then the sort
of flip side of brick and mortar retail
that's just one story
of many and uh and i know this is not
the last time we're gonna hear about
andrew yang and ubi and
and i hope it actually comes to pass in
some form i don't
look i i don't even know i can't even
say unequivocally this is the right
answer
because i don't we've not really seen
tests on this scale we don't really know
but we need we need some kind of
pragmatic testable solutions that get
input we know
someone should be throwing down for some
multi-billion dollar tests
like we really need to get after it
[Music]
[Applause]
you know here at yang speaks we are all
about protecting
our data i am so thrilled that prop 24
passed in california california's are
enjoying
higher data protection rights they're
going to create a new data protection
agency just for california
and if that sounds cool to you and
you're not in california then go to your
state legislators and say hey
how come californians have better data
protections than we do here in wisconsin
in michigan in ohio wherever let's have
the sweep the country
in the meantime if you want to protect
your personal data every time you use
the internet
we recommend expressvpn vpn stands for
virtual private network it's like you
beam into the internet
from someplace else no one can track
what you're doing
they can't sell and resell your data
it's like you're a ghost
a spy someone really cool from the
future
who no one knows what the heck they did
if that sounds good to you expressvpn
is your product visit expressvpn.com
yang that's e-x-p-r-e-n
dot-com gang for three months free with
a one-year package
this is the number one rated vpn by
wired cnet in the verge
visit expressvpn.com yang to learn more
i'd love to unpack what you just
expressed
correctly about the retail experience
about self checkout
and the rest of it i think we all dream
about going into a store just grabbing
the stuff we want and then walking out
and having it magically
uh scanned for us and debited how many
of us have not
had that thought when you're behind some
people in line let's say
it's like an airport store and you're
like uh you know i'm kind of in a hurry
here and like
you know he's out yeah
and then yeah so so
the person in front of you would be
taking their sweet time or
their right now another variant of this
is there is a self checkout but you're
like uh like i
you know it takes me i'll just say for
myself it takes me an extra number of
seconds to identify the barcode
uh and then sit there and sometimes i'm
an idiot just going like
like swiping it back and forth and
waiting to get some support
oh yeah been there yeah so we've all
been there so you dream about a world
where it's like look i just take the
thing
you know like that you understand based
upon the
rfid chip or the uh barcode that i moved
um that this just happened and then you
know who i am because i
like scan a credit card on the way in
and it just gets magically debited so so
that's a customer experience that we can
all get behind i think
um and i know you've been investing in
companies that actually are helping to
make that possible
um for and it sounds like due to the
pandemic
interest has only gone up uh in the
assistance
yeah and you know standard cognition is
the one example that comes to mind
where yeah we backed it they're going
head-to-head with amazon
against amazon's version of this product
amazon go
and they're basically the ones standard
is the company arming
uh every other retailer to get this
technology
to compete with amazon go stores
essentially and
and yeah it means you know in a
post-covered world it means fewer humans
in a store
um so so more safety basically you know
fewer people sort of
you know touching your things or you
know interacting
closely with you um but it also
is not just a great user experience it
also means that
for the the on the retail side
the focus of the employee in the future
of retail
is the kind of work that is more human
and and so it's like i could pick on
pick on your favorite big box home
improvement store
and and there's that great ron swanson
clip where he walks in
and the guy's like hey how can i help
you and ron's like i know more than you
and he just walks by him right because
you know the i think in the ideal
scenario
our retail experiences they still
involve humans
in the right places in the ways that
humans excel at
where you want empathy where you want
creativity my first job was in retail at
a comp usa
rest in peace cop usa and i was 15 years
old
trying to convince people or basically
help people buy the right computer or
the right mouse or the right
whatever 15 year old alexis would have
been very helpful when you're trying to
pick out that mouse
being like yeah i think you want the
optical the tracker
well i i was i was a bit of a gamer
um so i could give good mouse
recommendations
but i also um
i think part of the reason i was fairly
successful with the job i mean computer
went bankrupt but that's not my fault
um was because i could have a good
relationship with a customer quickly
they trusted me
and i could talk to them like a human
about things that were
a mouse may not seem complex but to a
lot of people who are coming into a comp
usa
they felt very insecure about what they
were about to buy and so there was a
humanity in the job
that was really important and i don't
think it
goes away for a lot of things for things
where i don't need
i like i don't need alexis to be like
let me tell you about the sparkling
water
like i don't need a lexus for that i
just need to walk in and get my
sparkling water and leave
um but but we're gonna see
that shift happen and it is gonna still
mean a lot of people that were normally
doing those jobs
are not right it will still employ
people
it'll just be a much smaller number of
them and they'll just do much more human
work
when the environment sort of calls for
it when the type of retail work calls
for it but
what do we do because this technology is
inevitable
and and i hope aside from a few luddites
no one is going to say ban the
technology
right well especially not now in the
time of covid because you could even
argue it from just like a public health
standpoint and a practicality and a
consumer enjoyment standpoint like if i
walk in and don't have to interact with
a soul
i'm not necessarily mad at that in this
environment i want my sparkling water
and i want to leave
and and you're right so then what is
so important is that
from i think the private sector has a
role
to be looking for more businesses at
least as an investor
to be looking for more businesses that
are still using technology
still software based or technology-based
businesses but that are
scaling employment for empathetic or
human
type work and there's a bunch of new
ones that i hope will be created
we backed a company called papa that's
doing very well that's it's grandkids on
demand
which sounds silly but with 10 000
boomers retiring every day
and and definitely not anywhere close to
10 000 like home health
workers starting jobs every day there's
a huge need
for empathetic people who can spend an
hour at a time
with the elderly doing everything from
like helping them with their netflix to
just
talking to them right loneliness is
actually an epidemic
and has health consequences and so
health plans are more motivated than
ever
to bring on these papa pals to take time
to be with their patients to be with
their members because it improves their
health outcomes
because it actually helps bring more
sort of data and feedback into the whole
conversation because they actually can
say like oh you need to go to the doctor
like let me let me drive you to the
doctor let me go help you pick up your
medicine like that
that solves a problem that we're not i
personally don't think we're ever gonna
have
empathetic like truly empathetic robots
um
elon begs to differ on that one but
for the time being there are still these
jobs that are the domain of humans and
should always be
uh that are very we're gonna have
we have to delve into this alexa's
humanity as medicine
humanity as elder care like that that's
staggeringly simple and profound
and important at the same time uh like i
want to hear more it's called papa
p-a-p-a yeah p-a-p-a
um and joinpapa.com is the website
um but what the ceo so what andrew
realized
was this didn't exist as a type of work
because it's not these are not medical
professionals these are not home health
care aides who are doing
you know drug administration and stuff
these are just empathetic
kind people and they go through diligent
screening process a lot of them are
actually
sort of college age students who are in
or learning medical professions so if
you are in nursing school
you want to make some good money on the
side instead of
say working that retail job at comp usa
you're a papa pal
because it's actually helping you
develop the skills that are valuable for
your career that only a human can do and
it's work
where you come home every day feeling
amazing like i also i also worked at a
pizza hut for a number of years as a
cook and a waiter
like if i could have been a papa pal
instead of a pizza hut cook i sorry
pizza i would have taken that
ten times over like i didn't have to
smell like pizza every day at the end of
the work i could
smell like lavender or whatever the
whose folks home smell like
and and actually feel really good about
the work i did and make make good money
i think you know his instinct
and it's only this company is only a
couple of years old it's made great
progress so far
tracking very well and i think it is
only a matter of time where in the next
five years
this will be a career option because the
market will have properly valued this
time
and the expertise who are great at it
that you can make a living as a you know
papa pal like this will be a profession
and it will be
something that like as a society will
already value because my god we don't do
enough to support our seniors
like it's easy society is all very quick
to be like that's a good idea
and and then once the dollars follow
that where you know
far too often we have a lot of these
jobs where everyone agrees it's a great
idea and really important but the
dollars aren't there
he's going to make the dollars get there
and
an entirely new class of people who
you know are growing up and
we could talk about higher education
maybe they decide that higher ed
you know and the costs of incurring that
assuming that doesn't change
the debt that they would take on isn't
worth it and really what they want to do
is just help people and help the elderly
and this is a path to actually make a
great living
awesome everyone knows that there that
we have an aging population
and like you said like 10 000 people a
day and
um in in some idyllic vision that many
of these older americans
are in pleasant community retirement
facilities and homes and they have
grandkids that visit them on the regular
and all this stuff but now in kovid
uh even if you had grandkids who wanted
to visit you they're not going to
uh so then the need for companionship
and help and you know human company and
contact
uh agree that it has a very um
crucial health benefits so even on that
level you'd be like well it's probably
gonna help
maintain this person's um like
functionality for
extra x number of years so under the
papa model
who is paying so you can do
direct so i like you or i could sign up
and just do
sort of the direct to consumer it's like
hey come come visit my grandpa
every week and it's just billed no
problem
um but where the real growth is is
actually from health plans
so health plans and these are folks who
are very very motivated
to keep their patients well right
and and it turns out for them it's
invaluable
because the more of this companionship
they can create the more of this
assistance they create
the healthier the outcomes are right
we're only starting to scratch the
surface
on loneliness as an epidemic but the the
papers are getting published there's a
real health cost
there's a lot of information yeah and
we're seeing it
i think now we all got a dose of it
right during covet and the lockdowns
there are a lot of folks who are really
way more empathetic with the idea of an
isolated senior than they have ever been
myself included right and so it sounds
like the papa pal
is meant to visit them in person um so
is there a ratio
where it's like 80 digital like you know
one visit a week like what does that
activity set look like
so this is an example every
okay if you ever a good question ask
every company
next year and venture investors are
already asking this question which is
how did covet affect your business
and what was the like the
there's going to be a very just like
that k-shaped recovery in the economy
broadly
there are really it's at the extremes
businesses either
had five years of what was going to be
steady growth and adoption
compressed into five months of rapid
growth
or the opposite papa ended up being one
of the former
they had virtual companionship as a
small part
of their business starting out and
kovid only accelerated the adoption so
now they're
they're majority virtual so it started
out a couple of years ago building the
software so that
like as a papa pal i could open my phone
have my appointments scheduled hit a
button and like you know
i'd see on the map where i'd drive to go
visit their home
and it would that was a very you know
physical in-person setup
but coveted accelerated the adoption of
virtual companionship and so that is the
dominant one now
and you know for a generation of boomers
in particular
they're all everyone's armed with a
smartphone now um you know the last
10 years in particular have brought
adoption to a level where yeah
you know a lot of folks are very
comfortable with
zoom and facetime that we never would
have expected
um a lot faster um thanks to this sort
of necessity of this
and and and pop has been a great
beneficiary of it and yeah it turns out
even the virtual companionship has the
same outcomes
uh for patients um which is something
like i this is something i can't
and this is another way i think i take
for granted having founded reddit
but i can't unsee how
real relationships are even when they
are digital
even when they are total strangers even
when you don't even know what the person
looks like
because i've seen that happen for 15
years on a platform where all you know
is a username
and the text they write so if that
exists and it's very
strong and in some cases stronger i mean
there are there are people on the
internet who don't know
anything about fluffybunny16
other than that's their username and yet
they have a closer relationship with
them
than the people they see at the office
or normally would see at the office
every day
well i hope it's been established that
you can build very very strong
relationships
um online digitally uh in in different
ways i mean heck there's that movie
uh her with joaquin phoenix like falling
in love with
his phone which i did not find to be
that implausible
you know uh and and so
so to use the consumer facing um
model as an example let's say that i'm a
very busy
parent um i'll use myself screw it
personally so let's say i'm a very busy
parent i've got parents who are aging
i can just sign up i can be like hey
great news
uh i've got some papa pal like uh for
you and then you like pick
pick them up so you can get it as like a
gift for your
aging relatives and then they would just
have someone who could
minister to their um tech questions and
because i i will say as a
an adult um i get tech questions
randomly from my parents
i would text after response from my
stepmom about which macbook she should
buy
and yeah i know i and it's it's tough
too because like i want to be
i want to be a good kid but i'm also
like just google it
you don't need to ask me this that's a
job for papa pal
it's time for tech enabled real time pal
unit to get in there that helped help
help us papa pal that like that
and and you know another interesting
thing that i wouldn't have expected i
gave
i gave andrew a hard time because he had
a 1-800 number on his website
back he was just starting out and we
were leading that round and i was like
really a 1-800 number and he's like you
don't understand like
this is the way to do it yeah you can
sign up through the website
but you put the 100 number trust me
because it's going to help
so much with with um onboarding and he's
been absolutely right
um so yeah if you wanted to schedule the
1-800 the pop-up file you could do it
online or download the app or you could
also just call one in other number
because
for a lot of their customers that's the
most comfortable way to do it and
it's that that little thing
like my my naivete arrogance in that
moment of like really a 1-800 number
that is why i love entrepreneurship
because
the founder the ceo he knew he
had to be humble enough to
go to where his users were or to build
something that
people actually wanted and
you know the founders who are successful
are the ones who can break out of their
own bias and actually
empathize and like so in that moment as
an investor i was clearly not
empathizing well
but but that's one of the things that is
um i think so needed right now
because we have so many big problems to
solve
so many and the private sector can't do
all of it let me also say i don't think
the private sector can do all of it
but there are areas where we need entire
industries to cre
to be invented we need a career like
being a papa pal
to be invented and and there's countless
more
because we need alternatives
for those jobs that are going to get
largely automated
and and i'm i i know this is not the
entire solution but it's a big part of
it and and that's that's
really the impetus behind why i do what
i do now because i need to help as many
of those things get started as possible
to me the ideal vision alexis is that
the government helps create incentives
for the creation of these jobs and
industries
you know what i mean because like right
now you look at it and you can find
uh an opportunity like papa pal where
there there's enough
money currently heading into it where
you can actually build a business around
it
but there are other things where you
look and say ooh that should exist
but there aren't the monetary incentives
in place right now
and this is where a lot of the you know
sustainability efforts go it's like well
we all can see that we should be
investing in
uh sustainable energy products but
sometimes the money's not there because
hey guess what fossil fuel is really
cheap right now and the rest of it so
like the ideal situations the government
actually helps create the incentive so
that people like you can invest in
the innovators and entrepreneurs who
want to try and build these things
um even papa pal when i think about it
why i was pressing on the
the uh business model in the revenues
where to me the social need for
papa pals uh is sky high
and then the question is whether uh the
folks that need a papa pal
have a health care health plan provider
that's
smart enough to buy it have relatives
that are smart enough to buy and have
the resources to do so
uh you know you can imagine a world
where the government was like
you know what like i'm not saying papa
pal's the way but
like we're gonna have like uh you know
some
stipend for anti-loneliness measures and
you can do whatever you want with them
you can
you know talk to friends family you can
like use a subscription service
like this i mean there is a world where
we can actually start throwing
uh higher levels of resources at some of
these problems but i
couldn't agree with you more that it's
innovators and entrepreneurs that
hopefully will
will give rise to the jobs we need
here at yank speaks we are all about
doing things better
doing things more efficiently doing
things more environmentally friendly
uh and this comes down to things that we
do every single day what could yang
possibly be talking about
i'm talking about bidets have you been
to another country
and been like wow what is this device
huh
like maybe they figured something out
they have figured something out they
figured out how to uh
to clean our tushies every single day in
a way that's more environmentally
friendly
it's more on point it's uh you know take
some getting used to
but uh but it's it's a better way to go
and most of us aren't at a point where
we're thinking oh like i'm gonna install
one in my home
so you know who has you covered toshi
has you covered because it's like an
add-on they stick it on an existing
toilet just any standard toilet and all
of a sudden it's like insta bidet
and it modernizes you it makes you more
environmentally friendly
it'll make you more sophisticated it'll
make you more european actually what am
i talking about i think asia is really
more into these things than anyone else
so if this sounds good to you check out
hello tushy
go to hellotushy.comyang to get 10
percent off
special offer hellotushy.com yang 10
off hello tishi.com
[Applause]
we have a responsibility to make sure
that although the playing field will
never be fully level
that we do the things necessary to
ensure like
we we get to some kind of of sort of
decent
some basic level of decency and equity
in this country
and i know it's such a god it's such a
polarizing thing right now
um and i just i hope we can get back to
some
good conversation and some actual
progress
um because i
the part that i worry about and you're
seeing there's a microcosm of this
in san francisco right now and i have
not lived in san francisco in a very
long time
um but you know there is
there there are people who are going to
be angry about
this technology about this innovation
and i think there are
plenty of reasons to come at the tech
industry there are like
absolutely criticism is an important
healthy part of democracy in our society
like that's that's
great we need that discourse um
but it needs to be placed appropriately
and the solutions we that come out of it
need to be effective at actually solving
the real problems
um because i
i worry i worry so much about the folks
who are getting left behind
and how that will just lead to more
resentment and ultimately more
desperation
and i just like we do that
it is not sustainable as a society it
just isn't and i'd
and i would be a hypocrite that's the
other thing that i wish
i i know these stories exist because i
talk to other founders about it
pretty often but i wish we did a better
job too
acknowledging all the things that helped
a lot of us successful
especially business people get to where
we were
and and there were things i mean my my
my parents telling me stories about
government cheese and i was like what's
government cheese
and and so there have been different
doors opened even for people like me
along the way where opportunities were
given
my mom was undocumented for three years
and
and my dad married her she overstayed
her au pair visa which is incidentally
where most of these most undocumented
people come from overstaying their visas
not a wall wall wouldn't have kept my
mother out all right it
it's overstaying visas and so you know
she's undocumented for a few years and
thank god ice didn't round her up
but that
i i i have to acknowledge the
opportunities that i got and the chances
i got it that my family got
and and know that
the extreme technology is amazing at
accelerating things and creating massive
growth but that there there's two sides
to it
and i think the conversations that
started as interesting
intellectual discourse like five ten
years ago around automation these books
we're talking about
that you brought to the masses with the
campaign
need to be at the forefront and not not
like in
five years or in ten years but like next
year
because the we just got a bump
uh a massive one because of kovid and so
we're not
like we're and again there's lots of
good that will come with that
but but also a cost if we're not
prepared as a society for it
and so it's made it even more urgent uh
in my eyes
uh for us to start talking about and
having intelligent conversations about
because man there's not a lot of that in
dc
no it's not great um but you hit the
nail on the head alexis where
uh the folks who are
angry and don't trust
that government or our uh
society is going to actually look out
for them and solve their problems in a
meaningful way
um they're being proven right all the
time you know what i mean there's
looking around
uh and and the thing that scares me is
that
there are so many folks who um
are in politics that we we essentially
are telling different stories um and
storytelling generally is losing its
effect because people are just checking
out more and more
as they they just say look you're full
of [ __ ] you're on tv
like you know [ __ ] you i mean that's
like the the general
thing and i hear that and i'd be like
yeah that makes sense you know like
you're actually like from your vantage
point that's actually a perfectly
rational
uh way to go uh and so
that's like the race we're against in my
opinion um that you have this winner
take all
uh economy that's just speeding up and
kovid speeding it up um
uh and and the folks one of the reasons
why i think you i mean you're
you're one of a kind in many many
dimensions but
um you're someone who sees the future
but you know still has the perspective
to know it's like look
like this is going to be great for some
people and like not great for others
it'd be
awesome if someone was actually trying
to figure out like how to account
for the the latter part of this equation
that you know i'm not a big enough of
like some kind of ideologue or [ __ ]
to think that the second half of the
equation doesn't exist and there aren't
human beings at the other end of it and
andrew this isn't just this isn't just
about the
the like the societal thing or like the
right and i i don't even make this
for me this is not even an issue of
decency or morality though it could be
and it is in part but for me i still
take it back
to the selfish capitalist reason we
should want it
which is if this system works
and we ensure that basic level of
decency and opportunity for everyone
we will get better stuff it means i will
get better founders to invest in i will
get a broader range of founders to
invest in who will build a greater range
of companies to employ more people to
build more dope things you could frame
it as
enlightened self-interest as much as
altruism
yeah like that and and i and i that's
it's so
ah it's so frustrating to me
to see it get so distorted
um because i i can't have
ha there's no way i could have this job
and not think that way
because i before doing right i started
my new venture fund 776 before that was
initialized
before that i was a partner y combinator
so i have over a decade met
thousands at tens of thousands out of
founders along their journey
in their earliest days and
it has only reinforced that quote uh i'm
gonna butcher the cliche about how
opportunity is not universal but talent
is
what is it talent is world universal but
opportunity isn't
uh uh
talent yeah google is because i'm gonna
um opportunity is not yeah talent is
universal but opportunity is not
there we go kennedy oday apparently said
that or no rye barcode that's what's
great on the internet there's a million
people
who actually came up with quotes so
someone said that and it's a good quote
but it's i i i am so
this whole career as an entrepreneur and
an investor in early stage entrepreneurs
has just reinforced that belief for me
and so i can't not believe that or want
that for this country
because i mean look i look i think a lot
of folks
are looking across the uh pacific ocean
for the first time a lot more critically
at china
and realizing
i mean i think i think a lot of folks
even i would say myself included
slept on a lot of their ascent and
i mean there's just technologically a
lot at stake here
um and and and and then the implications
of all of that um and i want us to win
frankly
right me too i want us to win
and yeah we are
i mean we're still there the the areas
in which we are lagging behind
technologically
are are shocking and like and some of it
is more
i don't know there some of it's more
jarring than others right seeing
homeless people in china get given money
via a qr code and then
like there are still there's probably
half half the cafes in america i can't
pay
via nfc right like we're still using
pennies bro we can't even get rid of the
penny
but much less get rid of cash i mean in
china a lot of places don't even take
cash they're like what's this thing
and and so here is all this fintech
infrastructure that's one specific
example but like at the end of the day
um we need to win and
i i well it's hard to win if you're all
turning against each other and having
increasingly
you know dysfunctional conversations and
your your government uh
is way way behind the curve and the rest
of it i mean it's hard to win if your
public sector is like a giant anchor
[Laughter]
holding us back man and and that's and
and so i hope well i hope the dialogue
changes we'll see
we'll see in a few weeks
andrew i want to talk to you about
something called noom which is basically
a psychology focused way to lose weight
get healthier get your mind right
getting in shape quote unquote is
something that we all say but it doesn't
actually have to be about
losing a specific amount of weight or a
magic number on the scale it's about
these healthy habits of feeling better
about yourself which is why the
psychology is really important so
if fitting into your favorite pair of
jeans is great but there are many
reasons you might want to practice
self-care and every person's different
so for me
i find that at least on the trail too
when you're eating like crap or you're
traveling a lot you're working a lot
like the energy starts dropping your
sleep gets a little inconsistent
uh the desire to have an alcoholic
beverage too often
uh creeps up so this
app and website and program noom is
pretty powerful and what you do is you
take this quiz
and we've actually done a fair amount of
these types of quizzes but i really like
this one because it's not
just like hey what's your weight loss
number it's like what's important to you
what are you struggling with what are
you
uh passionate about how busy are you
what is bothering you it's just stress
level is it eating it's nutrition it's
digestion whatever it is
so you create this quiz and it takes
like three minutes or so if you take it
a little more serious put more thought
into probably five to six minutes
and when you're done you get this plan
and
it's 10 minutes a day of either focusing
on your diet or physical activity or
meditation or whatever you think is or
whatever they determine is
helpful for your efforts
and for your plan and so for me i am on
a
getting shape plan by middle of january
which concludes a little bit of working
out and a little bit about diet
adjustments and i'm just getting started
but i've loved it so far
because it's simple and it's not trying
to hit a home run on your first at bat
like a lot of times when i
get back into working out i think things
like noom are the future
noom represents that the best
application of technology to actually
make us
healthier happier sign up for your trial
today at noom
n-o-o-m-dot-com
speaks visit noom.com speaks
to start your trial today
[Music]
[Applause]
i made that decision to step down from
the reddit board in protest back in june
after
george floyd and you know i you were
really
indeed a person of color uh you know
just as you
you'd requested um so
i was thrilled to see that that reddit
passed
um or started adopting a bunch of
anti-hate policies and then forcing them
and so i was relieved to see all of that
happen
um but i really meant it when i said
that i was thinking about a future
conversation with my daughter
about the work that i did and
i i really want from that point i wanted
to start making sure that i was making
i was running things through that lens
and like i'm a very competitive person
by nature
i have like a futurist you're like
talking to future alexis being
like hey what the heck what the heck do
you do
and look and i i carry an extra
responsibility right i have a black
daughter
whose mother is a superhero and who for
the rest of
like olympia will have people her entire
life
telling her what an impact her mother
made on their lives total strangers
right we'll say like oh my god your
mother gave me the confidence to do this
you're
like i i will say serena is a superhero
yeah that's a true statement
[Laughter]
it is incredibly liberating because
to have a partner who's achieved all
that
and know that just i like there's
literally nothing i could do
i could build a hundred amazons
and i'll it still won't have the impact
that that little girl from compton had
with everything she's achieved and will
continue to achieve it just it won't and
that's
that is a liberating thing it then makes
me realize
when i have that conversation with my
daughter i really need to bring my a
game
and and have a very very strong story
about what i do
how i made my money and and the things
that i really care about the things
because i love i've
i've had the greatest gift of loving the
work that i've done every single day
since college
and it is it really is i mean the pizza
job didn't love it uh but
but this i've loved it and so
george floyd's murder and then the
conversations around that and after that
really primed me to think like okay i
need to run everything through this
filter and so
um i really see it as a responsibility
to her uh to make sure that i'm putting
all of my efforts my expertise
my network the things that i have um
towards building a better future for her
and everyone and you really else that's
the nexus so you're like the nexus of so
many of our
national um trends and uh
struggles alexis in you in like a human
being
it's fascinating it's i've had a lot of
front row seats
to a lot of stuff and and i do think
being in an interracial marriage has
been a huge asset
um for lots of reasons not the least of
which is
um i am able to get
perspective every day that i wouldn't
normally get
um and and it's i think it helps me be a
better investor i think it helps me be a
better business person for sure
and and i still take away from all these
experiences that
the next 10 15 years i i really need to
spend
trying to help build as many meaningful
companies as possible
and even rethink the ways that we do
venture in order to make sure that we're
benefiting from the talents of as many
people as possible and
that's beautiful all right and necessary
i'll give you the
the little like a small example that we
announced yesterday because um so
caitlyn
holloway who is our she was the head of
people in culture who came in not long
after i came back to reddit and
she took a huge chance on us was a big
part of that whole turnaround and
growing the org from like 50 to 750. she
came over with me to initialize and
she's just come over now to 776 and
um her people and culture expertise and
that background
as an investor is is valuable for for
lots of ways not just because more
founders are thinking about this
than ever um because they realize if you
get this right early
the roi is massive uh competitive
tension is higher
uh recruiting is much easier and and
cheaper and it's just
the company just works better it's a
higher functioning unit
um and one of the things i challenged
her with was like what are the things
that we can do who are the best firms
at supporting early stage founders as
people
because that's you know an early stage
company might just be two entrepreneurs
three tops and and they're everything
right they're trying to keep their burn
rate low and they're the entire business
because they do everything
and and you know we noticed felicis
another venture firm
has this great program they launched
last year i think it was where they give
one percent of donated capital
to or make it available they pay in at
one percent of all
they invest um to be available for
mental health for founders
so if a fellow oh wow therapy very very
helpful this is pays the bill and i'm
like right and and i'm thinking about
this and i'm like god this is genius why
doesn't everyone do this and i'm like
okay caitlyn we need to do better
so so she announced we're doing a two
percent program about society-wide
imagine right if one percent of us gdp
went to mental health resources yeah let
me do some math on that
that would be 220 billion dollars of uh
mental health resources available to us
uh yeah that and i think that would be
enormously helpful
it's such a massive crisis a need right
now i mean like we're we're all losing
our minds and
that's among like the highly functioning
of us i mean like there are folks that
unfortunately are disintegrating every
day in this environment
yeah and imagine if you're worrying
about the rent bill and everything else
and so
yeah i want i want us to set this bar
because i realize we're among the most
fortunate so let's set this bar
let's show that it's a great return on
investment and
and she had the genius insight and this
was something she built at reddit
it's what i just love it so much
everyone should do it set this industry
standard
for everybody but yeah continue so so
she
she she built this at reddit 2 where um
you could use dollars
not just for for say therapy uh but also
for personal development and so for one
employee it was actually surfing lessons
what to avoid burnout was surfing
lessons
god bless that's awesome so exposure to
nature
been therapeutic effect yeah and so
so let's trust people look this is kind
of like a ub i think
let's trust people to use those dollars
responsibly for what they say is
self-care and yeah if they
you know if they want to spend uh five
grand on cheetos you know we'll pull
them aside and be like
that's not so good but i guarantee you
that surfer is more mentally healthy
than the rest of us
[Laughter]
and and then let's do this in in public
so like every year
publish a sort of audit of how people
are using those dollars not not
disclosing names but you know talk about
all those things
and then went a step further there's
another one percent
which is for family needs and so that is
dollars you can access
if you need an emergency babysitter if
you're trying to move your in-laws into
your home we'll cover that
if you've got a sick family member you
want to go see we'll cover that
incredible it's the cap and you know the
other thing i love about this alexis
is it actually throws real resources
behind it because a lot of orgs would be
like we care about your mental health we
care about your family
this is like doing it we're going to
designate one percent of invested
capital to do these resources it's like
a totally different thing
and and i why i love hearing you say
this man because
i this one this one hits me personally
because she she proposed this to me and
i was like you have no idea how amazing
this idea is so you know early
and again we talk about the roi of this
this is i wanna
like this we're doing this for
capitalist reasons okay
the uh i was in the first batch of y
combinator
2005 fresh out of college you know two
months in
literally in the middle of the batch
reddit is just starting to we just
launched it it's starting to make a
little traction
i get a call uh my mom has been
diagnosed with terminal brain cancer
and we're in boston at the time uh
they're living in baltimore
and obviously i fly home and and i start
splitting my time i start spending my
weekends down in baltimore i fly the air
tran from logan to bwi
uh for a number of weeks and
in that moment and this is no disrespect
to yc when yc was just getting started
like there was
everyone it was very much a startup they
were figuring out 2005.
but in that moment if they had said to
me hey look alexis
you know we have dollars set aside for
this um
we know you're going through a lot
you're obviously very important to this
company
and thus very important to y combinator
but
this is very important to you and in
order for
you to be successful you've got to be
right you've got to feel like
you're in as good a place as you can be
so we'll cover those flights
right i would have been spending the
last 15 years
every time i got on stage every time i
got in like that would be
like i mean yc obviously didn't need the
help
but think of what uh what an impact it
would have made
for a minimal investment and so i can't
help but look at it personally and think
let's have this as an opportunity
because even if only a fraction of our
founders take advantage of it
the ones who do for the rest of their
lives will think differently about us as
investors
and we'll think differently about their
expectations of other investors
and and move move this industry forward
and caring about someone as a person a
non-economic actor
is a is the best way to build trust uh
and
a long-term relationship you know it's
like a time your manager actually
clearly
cares about you on a personal level it's
like
an enormous deal and so if your
organization actually
frankly like formalize it so it's like
look we care about your family and again
it's
not just us blowing smoke like we'll
actually put
resources to work
[Music]
have you wanted to be athletic have you
also wanted to be green
then we've got the product for you
athletic greens
uh what what is athletic greens it's a
nutritional supplement
what it is it's a mix you put in with
water and all of a sudden all of these
super vitamins
and minerals and probiotics and
everything
that they've scientifically engineered
to be that supplement that you've been
waiting for
that's athletic greens i gotta say you
take it uh it becomes part of a ritual
and then you feel like you did your body
good and your body returns the favor
your body's like ooh
what is this you have given me this is
unusual this is stimulating
uh and then you feel better and then you
do it on the regular and all of a sudden
it feels like you had a much more
complete diet it's kind of a hack
i'm sort of uh i'm sort of someone who
likes to
do things efficiently and athletic green
is a very efficient way
to get the nutrients you need in a way
that you can actually do
so if you're looking to upgrade your
multivitamin to take one
nutritional formula that's going to help
cover you every single day
check out athletic greens it makes
getting high quality nutrition
incredibly easy all in one product go to
athleticgreens.com
yang you'll receive up to a year's
supply of liquid vitamin d for free
with your first purchase ooh free liquid
vitamin d
it's like sunshine in a bottle again
that's athleticgreens.com
[Applause]
the biggest resource that that they can
activate is your time
you know what i mean like if if you uh
have
time that you need to dedicate to it and
they are cool with that then that that's
like the biggest sacrifice an org can
make
oh yes and and time dude andrew you've
got kids
i'm and i'm gonna have you on once we
resurrect season two of business dad
we're gonna turn the tables i'm a
business
and and that that time
math never really it's funny i it's like
before kids after kids
and and sorry to my wife but it really
the math only started mattering on
another level
once kids entered the picture at least
for me because
it put a laser focus on on time and
wanting to
and i still fail at it but wanting to be
when i'm with
her like all in and and
really trying to seize those
opportunities and those moments and give
them my all because again i
i love the work i do it's r it's
actually like
it is a great gift um and then the curse
of it is
like sometimes i want to keep doing it
um when i shouldn't be
and and trying to find that balance is
always a challenge but
i i have a new kind of empathy now and
so i mean heck i
i want someone who is a parent to
make sure we're the first call if
they're a founder and they happen to
have kids
i want to make sure they're picking 776
first not just because we have these
dollars available
but because they know we empathize and
and
we care and and that
isn't it's not actually that
generous like it's not it's just that
the bar is
so low and and so much of this industry
is just still
it's very antiquated very financed very
like pe like it's just a different
it's a very it has not adapted to the
world we're living in it adapted
yeah it's true and and i agree with you
that when you're a parent too
like and if you're a founder who's a
parent like that the entire thing
uh all of a sudden the math stops
working
in in a way that it has worked at every
point in your career up to that point
so if you're an investor who understands
that uh it can help them
um manage it and accommodate uh you know
like the the very real demands i
i think that would be also like a huge
difference maker i think someone like
you becoming
um uh dad's actually good for the
industry alexis you know what i mean
it's like we should almost ask everyone
but it's like oh maybe like i have kids
and then maybe you'll understand what
the heck is going on like with
with these folks i agree and well it
hasn't always worked out because there's
some of my peers who have had kids and
still don't seem to be too interested in
the uh
society they're leaving that's weird uh
that one's so weird to me
like i'm on the record saying i never
would have run for president if not for
um our son being born now i can't
believe this [ __ ] alexis he's gonna be
eight
like that's nuts but like the first
couple of years of his existence were
such
like a stretching of the soul and an
education for me where i
i thought i knew what was what and i did
not know [ __ ]
then you look around and you look at
like anyone
who's like a parent particularly a
single parent single mom and like 90
percent of the parents
uh single parents in this country are
single moms and you look at them and
you'll be like you are capable of doing
things that
uh i uh would not be able to do like
you're you know you're a superhero
uh and then you look around and then you
start realizing just how distorted our
thinking is on so many of these things
um and that's what led me to run for
president it's like the need to humanize
uh alexis i came into this conversation
hoping you would give us a glimpse of
the future
and you gave us three big ones uh
already one is
the uh de-clerking
of many retail environments and sort of
upskilling the folks that are there but
also
like the seamlessness of that experience
that is not just going to be these fancy
amazon go stores that they're
prototyping like it's going to be
everywhere the papa pal
where we we can essentially unite folks
to
look out for our loved ones or they can
knight them themselves uh
and i i think there's like a really
important mega trend there which is
essentially
um a marketplace for
empathy uh companionship
help um an antidote to loneliness
i think that stuff's going to be very
very important and there are folks
listening to this who are just like that
sounds super wack
it's here to stay like this is not you
know it's like you could you can wish
that we all were like
back in another time in our lives where
we all got together and bowled
and you know and like everyone's parents
were like like living in
um you know they say you you might be
like you can wish that but
time like time is not um heading in that
direction
uh and then the third mega trend you you
identified which i love
is this investment in mental health and
family resources at an institutional
level that
if you were to do that like that
actually and i'm going to say you're a
very smart investor and it's like it's
good for
even if you just were to go in terms of
capital efficiency and high functioning
orgs like this is a great
investment this is a win you know it's
like like you have
like a more uh balanced less stressed
out
more functional founder management team
workforce etc like you know it it pays
so those are three enormous mega trends
also
your championing family paid family
leave
it it completely also makes sense on
every level
um so you you delivered man three
megatrends
yeah which was sort of like what i had
in mind was like i wonder if like uh
because i knew you would because you're
you're literally staring at the future
all the time
um and and one thing i love about you is
like you've worked in the future but it
has not really
changed your fundamental humanity like
the deeper you get into a space the more
um natural it is to frankly uh
kind of adopt the values of that
industry town uh job whatever it is and
kind of lose your essential humanity and
that's true
uh in dc it's true in hollywood
it's true on wall street it's true on
silicon va in silicon valley where you
just like get the random person
who's been in that environment a lot of
times they kind of give off things where
you're
like um like like this is almost like as
if it was
uh scripted like you know you're like
the scripted
scripted dc bureaucrat
yeah there's so many like you've met
them i met them like
and you have defied that um in a way
that
is is such an incredible thanksgiving
example really really i that is actually
very very that's like the highest praise
i can think of coming
from no that's it really is
the only secret i can come up with has
been and
you touched on it which is i actually
just don't spend
a lot of time in the tech community
i and i've been a nomad for the last
like
decade i mean my working life really the
last 10 years
has been traveling before i met my wife
so like five years ago and earlier i
would travel usually between new york
la san francisco and then other random
places
almost throughout the year and i was
always very comfortable doing that and
then
you know start dating get married to my
wife have a baby i like seeing them so i
travel most of the year to make sure i'm
never away for more than a couple weeks
and it's actually been fun because now
that everyone
is in zoom land i'm kind of like bane
in batman where he's like he's like you
you really adopted
the zoom lifestyle i was born in it
molded by it and like i really
feel naturally like i feel pretty
comfortable being in zoom for most of
the day because i've just had to do that
for the last 10 years and i haven't had
this now i haven't had to travel as much
which has been
actually kind of nice but um
that has dipped me into so many
different communities so many different
industries so many i'm i'm naturally
intellectually curious person
such that i never drank enough of the
kool-aid i mean the downside is i also
feel more like an outsider in the bay
area
i definitely don't have as strong of a
network in the bay area
but um i think being a generalist in
that way and being more agnostic
has has served me quite well i think i
think it helps
helps me find a wider range of founders
invest in better companies help them
more all that other good stuff you have
a completely different perspective man
than someone who's
like been in that town usually that town
the last number of years because that
town has really gone in a very
specific direction the last number of
years
and i and i look i maybe this
is you know and there is a flight from
san francisco happening right now and
it's
it's obviously the most wealthy and
movable
who are fleeing so we'll see what impact
that has
but i think over time um
the fact that those of us who are in
this industry of tech
are able to do more of their work from
almost anywhere
we're going to say i think there's going
to be a serious shift in where people
are living and where they're spending
their time and
i mean we're building 776 to be fully
remote from day one
most of the companies we're getting
pitched are either
at they're either flex where there's a
few of them in the same space they get
together like once a week
or they're fully remote from day one um
i i hope that one nice outcome here is
it's gonna mean
just that broader geographic diversity
of where people are
is gonna mean that like you'll get done
with your meeting you'll go out
and i don't know you'll be on a farm in
wyoming and you'll go down to main
street and you know it's a
population 5000 because you just like
the mountains and you hate
you hate just city life and you'll just
have different conversations at the cafe
you'll have a different community that
you live in and engage in
and and i hope that means a healthier
we'll see but i hope that means
healthier orgs
because we're sort of getting exposed to
more ideas
and i mean that was the the other thing
that i really enjoy is that you're such
a not
politician that like when you get in the
the semi with the truck driver and talk
about
what he's excited about or what he's
hopeful about or what he's afraid of and
what he thinks of automation etc
it doesn't feel like a politician
pandering it
it actually looks and feels like a human
being genuinely interested in another
human's way of life even if it's
totally like foreign
want to know and it shows and that's
and i think that is if there's any
reason or if there's any way
that uh i think i mean you haven't
you haven't plumbed the depths of dc but
i don't think it'll ch i don't think it
will change you when you're president
i think i'm a little bit too at this
point fully formed to like show up there
and start drinking the dc cooler right
like oh this steakhouse is unbelievable
i i don't even know how the dc uh
you know like uh repartee goes dude they
weren't
they weren't suppose and i it's so
dangerous to go back to like founding
father's intention but i feel good about
this one
like this wasn't designed to be a
lifetime appointment
it wasn't designed to be a career it was
designed to be service it was designed
to be
okay like i'll leave my family and i'll
go up here and we'll do this work
because it's really important for my
community
and it's not like oh this is what i'll
do for the rest of my life and i that
whether it's term limits whatever
they're there something has to change
their term limits
right because that that
it is it is clearly a time i've got a
master plan too alexis
my plan is to say term limits but
current legislators are exempt
uh and then they'll be like okay and
then those get off their back and then
you know eventually they get father down
like that's master plan
anyway i've got i've got got a few
master plans trying to
make make some good things happen it
would be it would be a boss move though
for someone to run
for senate or the house
maybe they have and explicitly say one
of the things they're running on is term
limits
there have been a few people who've come
out for it there were maybe a dozen
members of congress uh including beto
who i'm friends with uh like kate came
out for term limits
i i think uh rokhana may be for them
he's your not yours but um
the silicon valley yeah yeah don't
equate me with silicon valley andrew
i'm a proud floridian so
hey people watching this when you see
the news story it says florida man
it's alexis
[Laughter]
do you know the reason why that's a meme
um just because there's always a new
story
yes that is true but the reason why and
this is i got to defend my
state now um florida has these
sunshine laws cute name where all of the
police records
are made public oh so it's just
transparency
who have a wealth of information now yes
florida is a very populous state
so there's just a lot more there'd be a
lot there'd be a lot of strange fact
patterns if you just took all the
information and dumped it yeah
i mean that would be true yeah and like
yes i will agree
it's a weird weird state that probably
has
crazier than average people like per
capita the craziness is definitely
higher in florida
but it's not as high as florida man
makes you believe
because it's it's the sunshine act that
makes all those
public records look at that a an
entirely rational explanation for
a phenomenon we've all become
somewhat familiar with again still
a really weird state but uh
it's not it's not a it's not a fair
fight
well alexis uh you make any place you go
stronger better uh more human really
great to reconnect with you and thank
you again for being one of the early
champions of the yankees
a thing really whatever whatever you do
andrew you've got well i see just about
anything you do you have my cosign
well thank you alexis uh you know i we
need to
yeah vice versa we need to try and solve
some of these problems that you're
uh and you're working on um that we have
we have to
create these opportunities and you're
one of the leaders in the space that's
actually
seeing the problems for what they are so
thank you
hopefully we'll have a chance to spend
some more time together thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode